Any second. All in favor. Aye. All opposed. Opposed. 4-1 here. Okay. Move it on to item 13 public hearing.
Public hearing to consider master plan application, MA number 23-23-5, third request for one-year extension of time.
For conditional use permit, number 2-1-0-0-7, location northwest corner of Pelley Road and beneath Boulevard.
APNs are 169-031-003, 169-031-004, 169-031-005, 169-031-006, 169-031-006, 169-031-009, 169-031-009, 169-032-002, and 169-032-004.
applicant is Summer Eagle LLC and REAP LLC. Mr. Del Rio, may we have a staff report on this item?
Sure. Good evening, Mayor Silva and members of the City Council. Today I will be presenting master application number 23-235,
which is a request to extend the time of a conditional use permit and a tentative parcel map for the properties located near the intersection of Ben Navis Boulevard and Peddley Road.
On your screen, you'll have a map of our city where the blue line represents our city boundaries and the red star represents the general location of the project site.
As you can see, the project is located south of the 60 Freeway and west of Peddley Road in the Glen Avon community.
Here we have an aerial view of the project site where the subject properties are highlighted in blue.
As you can see, the site is divided by Ben Navis Boulevard. The northern portion of the project site is located on the northwest corner of Peddley Road
and Ben Navis Boulevard, while the south portion of the property is located on the southwest corner of Avon Street and Ben Navis.
Collectively, the site is 5.36 acres in size.
The project site has a general plan land use designation of commercial retail and it is zoned scenic highway commercial.
So both the land use and designation allow for retail and service like uses like restaurants, offices and grocery stores.
The property is located east, west and north of the project site.
I'll have a commercial retail land use designation and also zoned commercial.
While the property is located south of the project site, have a low density residential land use designation and have an A1 or light agriculture zone.
When you look at your screen, the vacant properties that surround the project site, those are all commercial.
While the developed properties south of the project site are residential.
So the applicant is requesting a one year extension of time for a tentative parcel map 37483.
This is the third request for an extension of time for this map.
The first extension of time extended the original approval date from September 12th of 2021 to September 12th of 2022.
Since the applicant did not record the map before the 2022 expiration date, they filed a second extension of time request
to extend the expiration date from September 12th of 2022 to September 12th of 2023.
And since the applicant failed to record the map before the 2023 expiration date, the applicant has filed a third request for extension of time.
Prior to the map expiring and is asking for the expiration date to be extended from September 12th of 2023 to September 12th of 2024.
The approved tentative parcel map divided 5.36 acres into six commercial parcels.
As you can see, the parcels are outlined in red on your screen and they are numbered accordingly.
Parcels one through four are located north of Bing Davis Boulevard, while parcels five and six are located south of Bing Davis.
The applicant states that the request for the extension of time is to allow sufficient time for them to correct minor formatting issues
and other minor comments on their final map application.
And currently the map is being updated and it will be submitted to the city for final review.
Because the corrections that need to be made are minor and the city and the applicant anticipate the map to be recorded by June of this year.
The applicant is also requesting a one year extension of time of conditional use permit to 1.007.
And I want to provide a little bit of background on this entitlement or this conditional use permit.
On September 12th of 2018, the planning commission adopted a resolution that approved a project that included a conditional use permit, a public convenience and necessity and a tentative parcel map.
That tentative parcel map is the one I discussed in the previous slide.
The conditional use permit approved was a two phase development for a Chevron branded gasoline service station and a drive through restaurant pad.
The first phase included a gasoline service station with a 2900 square foot fueling canopy for six fuel dispensers.
And that's highlighted in yellow on your screen.
And the first phase also included a 4500 square foot convenience store with a 2100 square foot office on the second floor.
And that's highlighted in blue on your screen.
The second phase was for a 2500 future drive through restaurant pad which is highlighted in pink.
The public convenience or necessity that was part of this project that was to allow the sale of beer and wine for off premises consumption from the convenience store.
And the approved tentative parcel map again was to divide the 5.36 acres into six commercial parcels.
So on your screen you'll see the approved site plan and I want to orient you and explain the elements of the development.
As you can see the site is located on the northwest corner of Ben Nevis in Peddley Boulevard and it is outlined in red.
The site is 1.72 acres in size and it's located specifically on parcels one and two of the tentative parcel map.
So I want to go back and give you some context.
The conditional use permit project was approved on lots one and two which are the lots that are on the northwest corner of Ben Nevis and Peddley Road there.
So these two parcels one and two have land use designation of commercial retail in our zone, scenic highway commercial adjacent to the south property line.
We have Ben Nevis Boulevard which goes in the east to west direction and along the east property line we have Peddley Road.
We can see a little bit of the 60 freeway off ramp north of the project site.
The project site has two access points on Ben Nevis Boulevard.
One of them is located sort of in the center there of the development while the other is located near the southeast corner of the project site.
Both access points will have stained concrete and decorative entrances and the site also has shared access to the west.
This will allow for the free circulation of traffic and vehicles from this site to any future sites that are located immediately west.
Street improvements along Ben Nevis Boulevard include a five foot sidewalk followed by a five foot landscape strip adjacent to the curb.
And along Peddley we have a seven foot wide landscape strip that's followed by a five foot wide sidewalk that is adjacent to the curb.
Dense landscaping is provided along both frontages there for Ben Nevis and Peddley Road.
And there's an eight foot high split face decorative wall that is being proposed along the north along the north and the east property lines.
Again, the project was approved in two phases.
The first phase allowed that 4,500 square foot convenience store which is in blue and the 2,900 square foot fuel dispenser which is highlighted in yellow.
Both of those structures are located on parcel one and the second phase allowed for the construction of the drive through pad which is highlighted in pink.
Overall the project provides 73 parking spaces inclusive of four parking spaces for ADA and the project provides 19% landscaping.
Here we have the approved tentative parcel map and that the extension of time is being requested for.
Again, the maps subdivides 5.36 acres into six commercial lots.
Parcels one through four are located north of Ben Nevis while Parcels five and six are located south of Ben Nevis.
And the approved gas station pad project that I mentioned earlier was approved on Parcels one of two, one and two of this map which again are located on the northwest corner of Ben Nevis and Peddley.
The remaining parcels here, so Parcels three, four, five and six, they will allow for future commercial development.
And on September 27th of 2023 we held a planning commission study session for a hotel project that's intended to be constructed on Parcels three and four of the tentative parcel map.
At this time formal entitlements for this hotel project have not been submitted.
And also the applicant has submitted entitlement applications for a two building mixed use project that is to be developed on lots five and six which are the lots that are south of Ben Nevis here.
At this time the project is still under review and the city has provided all interagency comments to the applicant.
So I want to talk about the previous approvals that have occurred on this site here we have a table with all the previous approvals.
So initially on September 12th of 2018 the planning commission approved master application 17245 which again was for that gas station and drive through pad conditional use permit.
The public convenience and necessity and the tentative parcel map and these three items are highlighted in dark gray on this table.
As you can see the conditional use permit the original conditional use permit was approved with a two year approval period and a September 12 2020 expiration date while the tentative parcel map was approved with a three year approval and a September 12 2021 expiration date.
Because the previous ownership did not construct the approved conditional use permit project before the expiration date the applicant filed a one year extension of time for that conditional use permit.
On February 4th, 2021 the city council approved that one year extension of time for the conditional use permit and extended the approval date to September 12th of 2021.
The hearing is highlighted in light blue and at this city council hearing the city council did impose new conditions of approval to this project and most notably the city council requested that alcohol cells be removed from this project.
And the city council also imposed conditions of approval to guarantee that the second phase of the drive through or the drive through building pad be constructed prior to receiving certificates of occupancy for the gas station.
The one year extension of time that was approved resulted in a approval period that stretched from September 12 of 2018 till September 12 of 2021.
Which is a three year time period and this three year time period is the maximum time allowed for a conditional use permit per the municipal code.
Because of that the conditional use permit cannot qualify for any further extensions.
So for the second time the previous ownership felt to construct the gas station and drive through project before the expiration date and they also felt to record the map before the expiration date.
So the previous ownership filed their first extension of time request for the tentative parcel map.
But the owners can no longer request an additional extension of time for that conditional use permit.
So what they did is they submitted a new conditional use permit application for that same project they had expired.
Essentially because the conditional use permit could no longer be extended.
The previous ownership submitted a new CUP application to keep that gas station and drive through project entitled.
On November 10 of 2021 the commission approved that one year extension of time for the tentative parcel map and they approve that new conditional use permit.
Which is conditional use permit to one zero zero seven.
That hearing is highlighted in light gray there on the table.
And the new conditional use permit was approved with the standard two year approval period and a November 10, 2023 expiration date.
And then at the same hearing the tentative parcel map was extended by one year to September 12 of 2022.
And once again because the applicant didn't record the final map before the 2022 expiration date.
The applicant submitted their second request for a one year extension of time for the tentative parcel map.
And on December 14 of 2022 the planning commission approved that second extension of time.
The tentative parcel map which extended the approval period to September 12 of 2023.
That that hearing is highlighted in dark blue there.
So now present day since the applicant has now recorded the tentative parcel map and has not yet begun substantial construction of the CUP project.
Today the applicant is requesting a third one year extension of time for the tentative parcel map to extend the approval period to September 12 of 2024.
And the applicant is also requesting their first extension of time for the conditional use permit to extend the expiration date to November 10 of 2024.
The reason the applicant needs the extended the additional years to record the map is to correct minor formatting issues and other minor comments on their final map application.
So the reason the applicant is the additional year for the conditional use permit is because the gas station and drive through project are now part of a larger multi parcel project that is intended to have the hotel and the mixed use buildings.
And those were not previously envisioned by the previous owner.
So with this new multi parcel project the ownership is taking some time to kind of do their due diligence submit some pre applications and get feedback from the city.
The applicant is currently working with the engineering department to finalize the map.
The city and the applicant expect for the map to be recorded by June of this year.
Title seven of the municipal code allows for tentative parcel maps to be extended a maximum of six years from the original approval date.
So should the extension of time be approved tonight the extension would be an extension of three years past that original approval date of September 12 of 2021.
The map has been found to be consistent with all the requirements of title seven the subdivision map act the general plan and the municipal code.
And lastly it has been determined that the extension of time is within the scope of the analysis contained in the initial study slash mitigate negative mitigated negative declaration that was adopted for that original gas station and drive through
that project.
Again as I mentioned in the previous slide the proposed extension of time requests are within the scope of the analysis of the initial study slash MND that was adopted previously.
And a previous environmental determination was prepared for the project stating that no substantial changes are being proposed for the project and therefore no additional environmental review is required.
It is recommended by motion that the city council conduct a public hearing and adopt resolution number 2024-02 approving a one year extension of time for tentative parcel map three seven four eight three.
And a one year extension of time for conditional use permit two one zero zero seven.
The determining and determining that no further seek review is required.
With that I will conclude my presentation and the applicant is here and we are both available to answer any questions you may have.
Thank you.
With that I would like to see any council questions for staff.
Yeah.
Thank you Miguel for the presentation just you already said a few things but I just wanted to clarify when when did the new owners acquire the property it was May of 2022 2022 correct.
And the permits were issued in 2018 is that correct and then the previous owners had already scheduled had already requested a number of extensions that is correct got it.
And then the project itself that includes the gas station and liquor sales that was approved before our ordinance that limits gas stations.
That's right.
Just confirming the timeline and then in terms of of alcohol sales I know there is a number of limits but is that liquor beer and wine or is it just liquor sales.
So the original approval in 2018 included a public convenience or necessity for beer and wine sales at this convenience store.
However when the first extension of time for the conditional use permit was requested the city council removed the alcohol.
Okay.
So so the project was extended without alcohol and that one eventually also expired.
So the old ownership submitted a new conditional use permit just to re-entitled the previous project without alcohol.
But at this point there is no alcohol being as part of this project.
They wouldn't be able to get a license to sell any alcohol.
So explain to me the PCN18001 where it says beer and wine on this page.
Sure.
So that was in 2018 they submitted an application for public convenience or necessity.
Okay.
That's the 2018 correct.
So they justified it.
City Council approved it at that point.
But then like I mentioned it was revoked at a later date.
And then to answer your initial the first question regarding would they be able to obtain alcohol sales.
That is a possibility.
They would have to submit a conditional use permit based on our new ordinance conditional use permit.
To request the alcohol sales and because they're in a oversaturated census tract and they would also need a PCN.
So it is possible for them to have alcohol.
It's not being requested at this time but it would require a conditional use permit and a PCN.
Got it.
And then has any tenant been confirmed for the drive-through?
Have they confirmed any tenants?
Not to my knowledge but they are here in case there's some new information on that.
Cool.
I'll ask them as well.
And then I know is there any more detail you can provide us to as to why all the extension request.
So I get it.
There's a new owner as of 2022.
Right.
But it's I think a lot of folks are hearing this started in 2018.
It's been six years.
If this was to pass, we'd go three years past the, you know, our limits.
Right.
So my question is what's the hold up?
In terms of this new owner coming in 2022.
Right.
It's 2024.
So I guess they had a year, maybe a year, almost two years.
Right.
So what have been some of the challenges?
What's the hold up?
And yeah, I just want to understand that better.
Sure.
To the best of my knowledge and when this project was approved in 2018, the, the original approval had a two year expiration date back when they requested that first extension of time.
I remember the justification was hardship due to COVID because that was right in 2020 when all that occurred.
So that was the justification back then the new ownership kind of acquired the property a few months before.
The tentative map was going to expire.
So like you mentioned, they've had like a year and a half, but they really fell into it when things were already kind of at the end of its life.
But to answer your question, I remember COVID being a hardship.
Now it's just really the new ownership's trying to understand how this previous gas station approval fits within their overall vision for that whole site.
They're currently looking into a hotel immediately west and then a two building multi mixed use project to building mixed use projects south.
So now that they've come on board, I think that's kind of the delays is going through planning commission study sessions for the hotel project.
And I believe we might come back for a study session on the mixed use project.
So acquiring that knowledge from from staff and from the council, I think that's what's causing these delays.
When they and I'll ask them some of these questions too, but when they acquired in 2022, did they also acquire the other property, the hotel property potential hotel property or did they already own that?
Correct. No, they they acquired the whole tentative map.
So they took in the whole thing. Okay.
Thank you, Miguel. Yeah.
Do we have any more council questions for staff?
Okay. So at this time, I would like to open the public hearing and call up the applicant.
Good evening.
I may lose my voice. It has. It's been a while since I've used it.
Council, Mr. Mayor, thank you for having us here this evening.
I'm Sherri Monroe for him engineering and development in Temecula.
And I am here as well in our representing the new ownership.
I'm here to answer any questions and ownership management is here as well for anything you need.
So.
Yeah. Thank you. I'll just reiterate. Can I ask questions?
Yeah.
Questions public hearing. Okay.
Do we have any public comments on this?
We'll come back to you. Okay.
No public comments. So then we'll bring it back.
Is it for this item? Yeah.
Go ahead. Come up.
In the council, I recall this project. Of course, it's the new ownership.
This was back in 2020 when we were still being approached.
By the old owners, the previous owners in regards to a extension of time.
Granted, this was the year of COVID. I was the COVID mayor.
It was a experience, you know, to say the least, but.
I was supportive then.
The same way how I'm supportive now.
Because good development begins with good retail.
I was against, you know, the moratorium that was placed upon the gas station.
Because I believe gas stations are one of America's number one destination sites.
You don't have to live in an area to provide tax revenue for a community.
It's right next to a freeway. And as I recall,
Mayor Pro Tem Burksen, he made a valid, a valid response then in regards to.
We don't want to see another situation that occurred on Lyman night where we're
approving a time tell of projects and.
Something's not being built such as the retail.
Basically wasn't being promised to be built because at that time,
we didn't know who the retailer was and granted there were several.
There were several EOTs back in 2020, you know, because of COVID, you know,
a lot of individuals didn't even know if they were going to make it past the night,
let alone a development for the future.
You know, the infrastructure based upon, you know,
Avon Benevis, you know, Pedley.
It's good development, you know, and now the talks of a hotel as well.
I mean, why not? I will always say this, California.
You know, we are as root of Valley, California's newest city and we are on the road
to being a California's greatest city. You know, the last thing that, you know,
I ever wanted to happen with us as a city is to leave a constant sour taste amongst
developers mouths, especially those that have good intentions.
So even though, you know, we are unaware of who the tenant is going to be
for the drive-through, I'm a firm believer in faith and if you build it,
they will come, you know, so with this project, you know, I would advise, you know,
of course, as a resident, you know, as a former counselor,
as a former counselor, as a former, you know, I would say, you know, move forward
with this project, you know, move forward with the EOT because at the end of the day,
you never know what goes on behind the doors on the front lines of developers
when it comes to engineering, when it comes to architecture, you know.
I mean, to my knowledge, Brian probably knows more than most of us, you know,
because he's in that field, but if we want something done right, you know,
let's bless the developers the right time, but at the same time,
look at what would be the negative costs going over that sixth year, you know,
extension of time and also the reason why, quickly, we can't grant them a liquor license
because the city is oversaturated. We only limited six, so that was talked about as well.
Thank you for your service.
Thank you. So at this time, we'd ask the applicant,
he has a five-minute rebuttal if you'd like to use that time.
Nope. And then any questions for, oh, to close the public hearing?
And then we bring it back up to council. Any questions for the applicant?
Yeah, just a couple questions for the applicant.
And there'll be similar to what I shared already, but in terms of tenants,
are you confirming that there's no tenant at the moment?
Hi, I'm Ronan Benet from behalf of the developers.
Thank you for your time today.
Yeah, we have actually quite, we have interest in the project.
Of course, as part of working closely with the city, and thank you for that.
There are a few moving pieces because the objective, as we relatively recently got into the project,
we understood that the primary objective of the city is focusing not just on the,
what we call the mobility station and the drive-through,
but rather on getting a hotel, doing a mixed-use project,
really, you know, we actually extended, we purchased a couple of other acreage
after the initial purchase just to make this happen.
So there are a few moving pieces, they're interested parties, we're very vigorously working on this.
Of course, in collaboration with the city, it's looking good.
Oh, yeah, and I appreciate your time.
Okay, and then what's your timeline, what's your current timeline?
You're requesting an extension, when are you going to finish the plans,
when you're planning to submit, do you have a sense of that?
So the answer would be sooner rather than later.
I don't think we're big.
Of course, I wouldn't want to name, just to be honest,
I wouldn't want to come up with exact timelines,
but certainly I see a lot of traction coming even within the next one year or so,
or less than that.
Again, we have a few moving pieces.
There are some meetings in the city we need to engage with,
there are some corrections to the map.
Our architects are very much engaged.
In fact, we've engaged in architectural firm for some of the additional pieces,
which is the hotel and the mixed use, one of the reps of the,
that's Nardi and Associates, well-renowned firm.
They've engaged also with the city.
So it's looking good.
We're pushing, obviously it's our interest as well to move as fast as we can.
So we're doing the best that we can to meet those objectives.
Okay, so one of the requests is for a one-year timeline, one-year extension,
for the tenured track map, but you said that your timeline is about a year,
so are you planning to come and do a fourth request?
That goes with some challenges for us.
No, not as far as we see it now.
Of course, again, the project being developed,
there's linkage, we're also working at a hotel,
but yeah, for this portion, I think the way it looks to me now,
it's looking good.
So I'm pretty optimistic.
I understand.
Do you understand that we have an ordinance that also limits gas stations
across the city?
Of course.
You're at the cusp, you're not.
There's a proliferation of gas stations, particularly in low-income communities
of color across the city, so I think that's been something that everybody's
been trying to limit, and you're already surpassing that.
So yeah, allow me to address that, of course.
We're actually very environmentally conscious.
The good news with this is even though, I mean, the original application,
this is prior to our time, named it as a gas station, and of course, we are
entitled to have that.
But our focus actually nowadays, and we've discussed it with the city as well,
is actually a focus on clean tech and electric stations.
So it's not going to be gas stations per se.
Of course, as of now, there's a move, a very aggressive move, wherever there are,
any kinds of gas pumps to move them to electric cars.
So that's another sort of dimension.
So yeah, one, I'm completely aware of what you've just noted,
and the second part of it is that we are focused on also essentially not really doing
a class to gas station per se, but everything is moving to electric.
I drive an electric car myself.
In all of our developments, we've been in business for over 40 years.
We're well reputable.
We do a lot of projects all over the country, certainly in Southern California,
which is our home.
Our focus is always actually on electric charges.
But yes, well, with it.
And I'll just do a quick correction because you're actually not entitled anymore.
Here are times up.
We're asking for an extension.
So just a quick correction, right?
Yes.
And then also, are you aware of the limits in terms of liquor, right?
The ordinance is that cities put in place to limit also the saturation of liquor stores and alcohol consumption.
Yeah.
We're aware of that.
Okay.
Any more questions for the applicant?
Being that you're, yeah, one quick question on that.
Being that you're aware, are you guys intending to apply for those permits or for those licenses?
The alcohol use permits?
At this time, I don't, yeah, we're not really seeing a need for that now.
Thank you.
No, not with these approvals on in front of you right now for the extension of time.
Question?
So we have some comments for it.
Thank you, Mayor.
I'll just, no more questions for you.
I think he's going to sit down.
Thank you.
The gas station moratorium, I know that was one of the things that I kind of pushed forward.
And I thank my colleagues at the time that were on the council that agreed with me.
Councilman Carmona made some good points.
If you look at where they are concentrated, they are in disadvantaged communities.
That's why we created the new regulations that don't.
Prohibit them.
It's just a different way to, if there are any future ones approved, very much more regulated.
Same thing with the liquor alcohol, right?
So we passed distances from schools, sensitive sites, et cetera.
So I have a history with gas stations because of that.
And I have no stranger to voting no on an extension for the Chandy shopping centers that were the
archos that everyone knows about at Mission and Felspar.
I mean, the Limeliner Felspar and Mission and Pyrite.
So at this point on this project, it's been so long.
And I remember Chandy promising every time it came up here that, oh, and this year, this
year, this year, and I know I've already know that I lost that one for one.
And even next year, he still didn't build something, but he finally did.
But as we all know, there's no tenants.
And that is something that sticks with our residents constantly.
So this project has gone through a lot of iterations.
I was in this council one.
We had that review and we removed the alcohol and we conditioned it because of Chandy's
projects that they can't just build a gas station and run.
They have to build it in phase, which I knew was a financial burden as well.
But our residents were tired of seeing what was going on in the city.
So with this on this one tonight, I'm going to really see where my colleagues are.
I have no, when we're either way right now is going to see where my colleagues sit.
I will hopefully make this quick.
I've met with these developers over the last couple of years since they purchased the
project here at City Hall on numerous occasions to go over their plans.
I was aware that they were going to purchase the second property for the hotel, which they did.
And as you know, I'm pro-development as long as it's good development.
This particular developer came in on the heels of, I will say the prior ownership.
When they asked for that extension, at the last moment changed my mind because of the son of the woman who owned it.
I remember that hearing and he said things that got to me.
So this project with the old ownership took a long time because I don't think the old ownership had the ability to move it forward the way it needed to.
The current development has plans, they've moved on their plans, they've purchased additional property.
I have no qualms in believing they're going to bring this to the finish line.
And I hope that you can do it within this 12 month period.
I'm for the 12 month extension, nothing's changing on it.
So there's no issues and there's no alcohol.
So I know that's not even a contention.
And even if they so chose to bring it back at another time, they can't do it without City Council approving it because it's in an oversaturated area.
So even if they wanted to, it would never be done just by them initiating on their own.
It would still come to this council to make a final determination.
So that to me isn't even in the cards for this particular item today.
I support it for a one year extension, but I would highly, highly suggest that you work with staff to get this to the finish line, get your map recorded.
You got 11 and a half months ish before us would be coming back on an agenda.
And I can't, you know, we never know, friend or foe, what your fate will be until we all decide at this point in a few moments.
So hopefully if it passes tonight, you will keep moving along.
That's all I've got. Thank you.
So I would agree with my colleagues.
I sat on the Planning Commission when it originally, well, I don't know if it was the original, but when we passed it, then I managed to make it to council.
Then we passed another round of it.
I know COVID had a big factor in it.
I would say bring us something.
I am in favor of the one year extension of time.
I would just say really bring us something.
We, you know, the Chinese situation.
So we're already at the, we were already on the fence in the beginning.
I understand it's been sold, COVID and all that.
So really bring us something.
Don't shrink us along.
And that would be my guess, my two cents on that.
And do we have any other comments?
I can share a couple comments.
Thank you, Mayor and council members.
Yeah, I believe I was in the Planning Commission when I voted for one or two of the extensions, maybe one of the extensions.
So I share in some of the concerns in terms of the actual project and the viability.
I'd like to, if this is, if this moves forward, I'd like to meet with you all and look at the project.
It has, it has very close proximity to our equestrian overly.
I believe it's right, neighboring right, right on the line.
I'm looking at the map right now.
So just to kind of share with you all some of the, you know,
some context about our community and, you know, just kind of how our community would benefit and perhaps utilize the space as well in addition to,
to outside folks.
That's what I have for now.
So with that, I'd like to bring it up for, I guess, a motion.
Do we have a second?
Yeah, I'll go ahead and second.
All in favor?
Aye.
All opposed?
No.
4-1.
So 4-1 passes 4-1.
Next item is council business, item 14, item 8, consideration of funding.
Aye.